[Music]  now let's get you up to speed on some  more headlines first up in our dancing  edition of no Intel Maxim's family  emergency Dancing with the Stars duo  Maksim Chmerkovskiy and peta murgatroyd  revealed they had to take newborn son  shy to the hospital just a couple of  weeks after he was born max tells ABC  News quote he got a fever and we had to  go to the emergency room hey shiz a ok  now but max admits to being an  overprotective dad and after this health  scare he says they probably won't be  taking the two-month-old to the dancing  set very often that little guy is gonna  be a disaster for everybody is in  trouble I just hope he got old pitas you  know just person how it is meanwhile  Peters in it to win it with bachelor  Nick they were all and Nick on the other  hand well he says he psyched about it I  am very very excited about the song I  was just gonna say then I have to dance  to I don't want to spoil it but I could  not think any more excited about  [Music]  you